As a human, for every click of a button
that you have in your test
which is thousands,
you can't remember.
Wait a second, I use this property,
but I'm going to change it.
You can't remember everything.
For a computer, that's like.
Oren Rubin, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders
It's been a while,
but I'm so glad
that I finally caught you.
How are you?
Indeed, doing great my friend.
How about you?
Doing fantastic.
You are so kind and gracious
to invite me to a wonderful dinner
a few months ago.
I don't know if you remember,
but you brought a great focused group.
We talked about testing.
We talked about research and development.
We talked about the struggles
of building beautiful products.
And it was very inspiring for me.
So, thank you for the invitation for that.
You're welcome, my friend.
Any chance to see you is great.
I love it.
Oren, you have a beautiful journey
from IBM to WIX to Applitools
to now Testim.io.
With a lot of things in between
that I didn't even mention.
But it doesn't do justice
to the core of your journey.
Tell me a little bit about yourself
and how do you even get involved
with testing?
First of all, you notice that it goes
from bigger companies
to smaller, like IBM,
I was employee 330.
At Cadence that was employee number 5000.
WIX that was 151.
Applitools, I was employee number one.
And Testim, that's employee number zero.
Yeah.
Wow. Okay, so that's a beautiful funnel.
And slowly through that funnel,
you're getting closer and closer to,
to this idea of quality and architecture.
Right?
I think quality was always there
in around me, like, for example,
at IBM, things needs to be tested.
I love doing that and
actually making sure,
when you, as an engineer,
you want to deliver to people, you want
to make sure that it's high quality.
Of course, and also
helping with the tools.
As a young engineer,
it's like I love those, actually.
So, later with Cadence,
I was a compiler engineer.
There's a language.
There's two languages
that were developed in Israel.
So, I was glad to be
working on one of them.
But the nice part is it was a language
for hollow verification.
So, that means my users, as they say,
were people that are testers.
So, to understand what they're doing
you need to understand a little bit about
test automation or in this case,
hollow automation.
So, I always had this thing in the
background, and even then with WIX,
of course, I did some side project
and that's how WIX got to me and said,
hey, we're moving from this spring
from flash to HTML,
come and help us build this product.
And everything was tested manually.
And so [--]
is a person that came that saw
that everything was
tested automatically and even had
a special special language for that.
I was like, "What? No way."
Are we going to WIX to run it manually.
So, then you start pushing in a company
which a company already
has a few hundred people, it's like,
it's not that simple to make the change.
But luckily, the amazing founders
and I worked closely with Nadav Abrahami
and Yoav Abrahami.
Omer on the technical side,
[--]
that an engineer
that turned into the dark side
of product and business.
But back then,
at WIX, I saw the challenge already.
And how to change a company and how
to make it from only manual testing
to be full CICD.
What was the most difficult journey
of taking a company of a few
hundred developers, you know,
hundreds of thousands or potentially
millions of lines of code and not just
slowly transitioning
to automatic testing?
I know how difficult it is to do it
when you have zero lines of code.
But how difficult is it to do when
you have a lot of lines of code?
So, I think in WIX
it was a little bit easier
because they were just building
a new product, so that made it easier.
But you need to convince
people, actually,
that their way of thinking
should be different.
And you need to find out
who are the people
that can move something
inside the organization.
It's always like that.
Whether that's
in the technical side or not.
But you need to understand
who are the champions,
who are the people that
you need to get them excited,
one by one, get them excited,
and eventually you'll have
the majority of people
that are rooting for that
and will start pushing toward that
and will make the change.
Okay.
So, Oren, I have a challenge for you.
Are you ready?
I want you to get me excited
about testing.
You already use testing.
Wait a second, are you talking about
test automation or Testim.io?
Let's start with this idea
of why testing is even important.
Well, you always test.
You don't even know about it,
but you always test.
The question is when.
The question is, who's testing it.
Are you testing it or your users?
So, bugs are your business
and it depends on the company
that it hurts you in a different way.
And some bugs like Intel had
that cost it four billion dollars.
And the branding.
Right. I remember that.
Oh, yeah.
And not to mention
spaceships that exploded.
It's very critical to make sure
that you're testing,
you're making sure that your product
does exactly what you want.
So, some companies,
very few, like Netflix, can say,
wait a second,
if if something doesn't work,
you'll come back in 30 minutes.
But in a lot of cases,
think about WIX
that someone wants to pay now
or PayPal or anyone that wants
to pay something for a product
that doesn't work,
for the next 30 minutes
they'll go to the competition.
Right.
So, you lose money.
Okay. So, I'm convinced
that testing is important.
But you know, when I started
my first few days as a software engineer,
I was told that before
I deploy my product
I need to write a bunch of manual tests
on JIRA, follow them manually,
and that's enough.
Then I'll deploy.
What's wrong with that?
What's wrong with the ideology
that I'll just write some manual tests,
I'll repeat them every deployment
and there's nobody better
than my own two eyes, right?
So, I think there's a few things
that actually happened
in the last decade.
One is that, we find out that
the earlier you find a bug,
the cheaper it is to fix it.
So, if you find it just before production
or a month earlier,
then that's a great improvement in ROI.
So, that's one thing.
The second thing is
you actually manually,
you can't you can't,
you don't have enough people
in the world.
Let's just say, your people,
there's a hundred developers,
if you want to run your tests
before every pull request,
and there's a lot of those.
And you need thousands of manual,
people manual test
that will go and click on stuff.
And you can't do that.
First of all, if you want to
go with a product
that was called Shift-Left,
you need a lot of tests.
And that means paralyzation.
And then you get this environment,
you want to run different browsers,
different parameters.
There's not enough humans in the world
and that's why we go to machines.
So, and they do it much better than us.
Much better.
And you're going to miss some stuff.
And the machine is not
going to miss that.
Even without coffee.
I have to say that one of the first time
that I use the snapshot testing,
it was still back in the IDF.
And I remember that
I was developing this website
and I've done the manual tests
and everything seemed good.
And I had just started playing around
with taking the snapshots
through Jest, I believe,
and all of a sudden it showed me that
that a part of the website
that I didn't even notice
started shifting.
And I could only imagine
how this could roll
and this bug would continue
and cost me more and more.
Oren, but I have to ask,
before we get to test to Testim.io,
you go through these companies,
you do all sorts
of different technologies,
and at the end you decide
that you're passionate about
automatic testing
and helping organizations
around the world to better test and do it
in a more fun and scalable way.
Why do you focus on that?
Why is that the passion at the end?
I think that you actually started
with the second thing of what you said,
which is I wanted to help and say,
I love, and so are you
we love to help people.
But now we need to understand
how can I help
and what is the best thing
that I can do to help people.
And of course, to affect
as much as more as possible.
If you work for one company,
you help them if you work at a company.
But if you deliver
a product that can help
thousands of companies,
then you get, you feel
you can help the large
scale of the world.
So, it starts with that.
The fact that you want to help
and the fact that you need
to understand what can I do best.
And I think,
when I'm asked about different questions
or talked to, before starting Testim,
I talked to so many VP engineers
in Israel and the world.
And in Israel,
it was much easier because everyone
is like in a walking distance
or nowadays, Zoom distance.
But you find out words
that what are those challenges,
what are their pains,
that's the most important thing.
And it's weird that a lot of of engineers
go to the "dark side" of the business.
And they can start a startup.
The most important thing
they need to remember,
someone told me a few years ago,
you start a conversation
not by explaining
what your product does.
It's explaining what is the pain
of the other person.
And everyone keeps saying things that
salespeople are sleazy and like,
no, it doesn't supposed to be like that.
Have a product
that answers someone's pain.
They'll want to buy it.
But usually a salesperson,
sometimes they have struggled to buy it.
Salesperson is just navigate that
and make sure
that they're going to make it
in the most easiest way.
It all starts with,
hey, you're solving a real challenge.
So, you entered the startup phase
very convinced that you're solving
a deep problem.
You've experienced it yourself.
You're talking to a bunch
of VP engineers.
You're doing your research.
What is the solution
that you come up with
that could solve this problem
for a lot of people?
I saw that most people
didn't even get started
with test automation.
And I have noticed trends.
First of all, there's actually a trend.
There was one that
code is moving to the front end.
Like every 10 years,
code is moving
from the back into the front
and it was mainframes
then that's the back end.
Then it was, first of all, PC,
the code was in the front end
then the web came along
and the servers, the code again was,
a lot of the most of the code
was in the back end.
And now we notice,
react, angular [--],
like so many of the code business,
critical business logic
was moving to the front end
and nobody knew how to test it.
So, everyone I see
that there's a challenge.
Everyone says, "Wait a second,
I used to have one line of code
in the front end,
which I tested manually.
Now I have a million of those.
How the hell do I test it?"
Right.
And of course, test end to end.
So, we saw the trend.
First of all, you see a trend
and you're saying,
hey, it's going to spike.
The testing in the front end
is going to trend.
And what are the existing tools?
And the existing tools,
if you think about that,
just understanding a megabyte
12, 15 years ago,
last time the front end was in the center,
it was so much information.
One gigabyte it was like,
oh, my God, it's so huge.
The methods, things like AI
didn't exist 20 years ago.
Think of the change that's been since.
And then you're thinking,
what has changed
and how can I use technology
to actually solve something
that's needed.
So, start with that.
So, you started with that.
And so, what is the product now
that you've been working on
for the past few years
that I've also had a pleasure
of playing around with quite a few times?
So, what we saw, what we said,
wait a second,
to help with end to end testing, we said,
one of the biggest challenges was that
the UI keeps changing all the time.
And all the current technologies use
one fourth that you have to say,
hey, find this button based on the test.
First, you have to name it.
You have to do it yourself.
And that's literally I could do it,
calling it like almost
like doing it manually.
And the second thing is that it changes.
The application keeps changing.
As a human, for every click of a button
that you have in your test,
which is thousands,
you can't remember.
Wait a second.
I use this property,
but I'm going to change it.
You can't remember everything.
For a computer, that's like
that's like a no brainer.
They can follow and forever click.
You can have thousands
of different attributes and features
and you can say,
oh, I can find it in more ways
than a human.
Things that a human
didn't even think about,
I can think of ways
to how to find that element.
So, in here specifically,
we took the pain that people had,
which is how do I test faster.
I want them released tomorrow,
why do I need to write a test for a week.
I need it in five minutes.
And the challenge of, that case,
it's called testability
or test flakiness,
and taking those challenges and saying,
hey, how can I have a solution
that solves those questions.
Right.
And that solution becomes Testim.io
based out of San Francisco.
Yeah. That's the beginning.
After that,
you see why people come to you.
And the more customers you have,
you understand what exactly they want.
You see more challenges.
And then you started seeing,
hey, I can do more things.
I can help them.
Then they started saying,
"Hey, there's duplications everywhere.
How can I find out?"
Then you're saying,
"Oh, we can use the same technology
to find all the duplications.
I recommend you
how to use a reusable component."
Those things always come
with talking to customers,
understanding their challenges.
Because the AI always ask one feature.
You talk to them,
you understand what the challenges,
and then you say,
hey, here's another feature
which is much better.
So, Oren, talk to me a little bit about
this feedback cycle,
this agile methodology
that you're using
of developing a product,
watching your users, talking to them,
understanding the pain points.
Obviously, as somebody
who's been doing it
for years, as an engineer yourself,
you can sympathize very, very well
with these pain points.
How do you then translate that
into a product that doesn't yet exist?
Because you're developing products
that don't yet exist.
You're taking pain points that do exist
and you're creatively finding
solutions for them through Testim.io.
So, how does that process look
like?
I think in my case,
it helps that I've been in this domain
for a long time.
Right.
And first of all,
there was a company
that was willing to pay
even before we had the product.
Wow.
That was, I think,
about $60,000 contract.
And I, showed them sketches.
So, I think they trusted me because
they saw earlier
when I worked in Applitools,
they saw me building a product
from idea to a real product.
And I think they trust this.
You need to build that trust
with the community.
But I think it's working very closely
with the customers from day zero
and ongoing all the time
working with them.
You have one thing
and that's in the beginning of a call.
Let's just say someone
is paying you already.
You have one thing
that you have to ask them
at the beginning:
what are your goals
and how can I make you
the happiest person in the universe.
And then you start thinking,
okay, let's do this.
By the way, the trick here,
the trick here is that sometimes
a person's goals and the company goals,
they don't necessarily
all the time align.
I think it's very important
when you're building a product, it's also
you need to start understanding
how do people how do they think,
what makes them happy,
and where do they want to be.
And it's funny because
it's like I want to ask,
where do you want to be
in five years?
You have to know that
in a 30 minute conversation.
And to understand that with that person,
where do they want to go
and make them happy.
So, there's two things, when you said,
when we're talking about sell,
the only thing is trying to understand
what people want as the individual,
second thing is what makes the company
or the manager,
what would make the manager happy.
I love that.
Oren, where do you see this going
in five, 10 years?
The industry,
not necessarily just Testim.io,
but this idea of tests first
and test driven mentality,
where do you see us going
in 10, 15 years in terms of development?
First of all, I think developers
is always talking about the Shift-Left
that developers do testing earlier,
I think developers do
also the Shift-Right.
Developers will be much more connected
to what's going on in production
all the time.
When they see something,
when something else doesn't work,
I think that everything
that's going on in production,
you'll understand.
First of all,
what are your users doing.
Right now,
when someone's writing tests,
they don't even know
what's going on in production.
That's crazy.
They don't know what are
their users are usually doing.
Imagine that you that you do know
what all your users are doing,
what are the things that you didn't do,
if something a bug happened
that you know exactly
what the scenario is,
automatically.
So, I think those are,
but that's usually 10, 20 years.
From that degree,
that's going to be much sooner, I think.
After that, I think there will be,
you will connect more the product level.
I think you'll be able to test more
or define what the scenarios
when you're talking about the product.
This is what I want the product to be,
okay, here's my test,
automatically generated.
Those would have to come.
I love it.
Yeah, I think it has to come there.
It will be there.
I love that.
And I had the pleasure of both
developing with testing
and without testing.
And I can definitely testify
that it's a different world.
And in building application,
there are number of times
that I found myself
breaking my head against the wall
when I didn't do test driven development,
it was awful.
So, if all my friends
at Stanford and 8200,
if they're listening to this,
I'm a huge believer both in testing
and Testim.io.
And thank you for introducing me
to this world.
A lot of it is due to the work
that you're doing with Testim.io
that I got involved more and more
and learn about it.
So, thank you for that.
But Oren, before we finish,
I need to ask you
for the most important question,
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
And I apologize in advance that I did not
tell you enough time in advance,
so I'm not going to hold you
accountable to that.
Do I have to describe myself
in three words?
However you'd like
to answer the question.
So, first of all,
I think like a lot of entrepreneurs,
I am a person that loves learning.
I love and I think
I'm doing what I
enjoying myself the most,
which is I'm learning every day.
Even years, even in the same company,
you keep learning it all the time.
So, I love that.
And but things that I think
the people don't know about me is that
on one hand I play the guitar,
I always played
at least electric guitar.
And on the other hand, I love rock.
And on the other hand,
I play Chess now, every day.
Actually, not just regular Chess,
it's Bughouse.
It's a chess variation.
Two people versus two people.
So, it's a little bit more,
you have to look at two boards.
And this the nice part,
it's
of course,
you have to think about, you know,
10 moves ahead, and of course,
there's another board.
But there's also communication
with other people.
So, I think, and I see
you like that as well.
I can see that.
It's not just about technology and ideas
and about cracking the,
the optimal just solution
on how to win your opponent,
you need to have a partner.
And you need to talk to them
and tell them what you need.
And you need them to help you out
and you help them.
Which is I think,
this is what I love most.
It's that working with people
and having that feeling
that we're all together.
The nice thing
I'm going to do right about this
is two things,
first, invite you to a game
on Chess.com;
the next one is looking at
this two versus two game.
Because it looks wonderful.
Oren, thank you very much.
Toda raba.
This was just wonderful.
Thank you.
You're welcome my friend.
Take care.